obrigada kelson pregada andré todo mundo
está organizando o ted aqui eu queria
falar que é um prazer tá aqui hoje para
falar de uma coisa que uns anos atrás eu
normalmente não falaria
eu tenho um histórico na academia está
costumada algumas palestras mas eu não
imaginava que eu seria a pessoa que
subia no palco para falar de comunicação
nunca pesquisa e comunicação antes mas
hoje eu estou aqui representando a mim
mas também algumas dessas pessoas que eu
coloquei aqui e essas pessoas não sabem
que eu coloquei elas aqui mas espero que
ela se sinta contempladas
o que eu fico feliz que hoje em dia eu
tenho uma comunidade ali no youtube e
que ela nem cabe nesses lá e algumas
pessoas tiveram ficar de fora isso é uma
boa notícia e eu vou falar porque nós
sabemos que as redes sociais afetam em
muito o que acontece em nosso dia a dia
e afeta as questões políticas do nosso
país e no mundo
este ano o datafolha fez uma pesquisa em
agosto e ela falou que um em cada cinco
brasileiros compartilhava notícias de
política no facebook no orkut zap e
quando eu estava trabalhando com o
eleitor especificamente foi determinado
que 72% dos eleitores se acessavam a
internet então pegava informações pela
internet
isso parece pouco mas é relacionado à
questão de acesso à internet no brasil
que infelizmente ainda desfalcam só que
tem bastante impacto de qualquer maneira
vocês sabem que em junho de 2013 o
impacto que o facebook teve em junho de
este ano organizações a de pessoas
meramente autónomas através das suas
associações alino whatsapp conseguiram
parar o país por uma semana da greve de
caminhoneiros e não há dúvidas de que o
facebook que o whatsapp e que o
audiovisual no geral circulando nas
redes sociais empataram em grande peso
as eleições deste ano no brasil e isso
pode ser dito sobre eleições em vários
países como nos estados unidos também
onde que o youtube
entra nesse jogo what's up ele é
considerado o mais usado de todos
what's up inclusive ele influencia
porque muita gente no brasil têm acesso
ao ataque no seu celular
e somente ao hat sap é o que é permitido
essa pessoa através do seu pacote de
dados
então elas informa principalmente pelo
sapo que chega lhe sendo uma notícia de
jornal de um portal o que está no
facebook um vídeo do youtube chega
através do sap mas o youtube não deixa
de ter um papel muito importante porque
ele vai estar faltando uma variedade de
idéias ali e hoje eu quero falar para
vocês porque que o youtube é importante
para se debater política
quais são os desafios que a gente tem
para debater política no youtube
e como eu imagino que nós possamos estar
facilitando esse processo de debater
política ali primeira pergunta se
responde pouquinho pensando que o
youtube ajuda a construir pontes
eu queria falar de duas pontes nesse
momento eu tenho um papel acadêmico fiz
meu doutorado a gente eu dou aula e uma
coisa que eu sei que na academia a gente
pesquisa muito
é muita pesquisa muito artigo sentir com
a livros sendo publicado palestras sendo
dadas bolsas do pibic todo mundo sabe
que pelo menos boa parte da pesquisa que
chega até hoje saiu de alguma
universidade quando tem uma manchete de
jornal que falar estudo de stall coisa
esse estudo provavelmente foi feito na
universidade e no youtube ajuda a
construir algumas pontes relacionadas à
universidade mas relacionadas à política
também
eu fui descobrir isso um pouco por acaso
quando eu criei esse canal aqui chamada
tese 11 é um canal que tem um ano e meio
mais ou menos resistência que se você me
perguntasse dois anos atrás eu ia falar
com você era maluco você estava
sugerindo prever aí o youtube mas
aconteceu e no que aconteceu o canal
hoje em dia ele ainda é um novato ali no
youtube ele não tem tantos inscritos
quanto os veteranos mas uma coisa que me
deixa muito feliz aqui ele tem inscritos
anteriormente leais inclusive algumas
pessoas que estão aqui hoje em mariana e
ocasião onde ele cumpre dois papéis
na minha ideia seria de criar pontes uma
entre essa questão acadêmica quase dois
milhões de artigos científicos são
publicados por ano no mundo isso é muita
pesquisa é muito artigo científico
só que infelizmente a maior parte desses
artigos não vai ser citada
então existem pesquisas que demonstram
mais uma vez pesquisa suas pesquisas
então meta narrativas então os sentidos
é existem pesquisas que demonstram que
dependendo da área até 80% dos artigos
naquela área nunca serão citados e se
eles não vão ser citados não significa
que não são pesquisas relevantes que não
são precisas de impacto mas que sim o
seu alcance está sendo limitado porque
na academia na pesquisa acadêmica citar
leva sua ideia mais longe ajuda a moldar
outras idéias a formar críticas são
importantes então isso é algo pra gente
ficar alertas sobre como que a gente
pode modificar isso
em outra questão também que hoje em dia
vários dos artigos até mesmo livros que
a gente encontra são difíceis de ler e
quando fala difícil de leão estou
falando só de jargão científico
conceitos teóricos palavras muito
específicas em latim
eu tô falando dificuldade de leitura
realmente porque há uma visão por aí que
pra gente ter um bom trabalho seja
respeitado a gente tem que escrever de
uma forma muito chique muito elegante
então as pessoas ficam colocando
palavras complicadas junto a outros
conceitos já complicados então isso pra
mim seria uma receita para o desastre
eu vejo hoje em dia que a cada vez que
um professor de redação num cursinho que
o enem está ensinando a escrever
hodiernamente em desde atualmente você
pode estar achando que isso não tem
dando nenhuma se você junta vários
ordenamentos com vicissitudes com outros
fins e combina isso com o conceito já
complicados você vai dificultar a
leitura isso vai dificultar o alcance do
que você está propondo que pode ter um
grande impacto na sociedade mas as
pessoas não estão descobrindo ainda e aí
tem as fontes políticas
as pontes políticas se tornam muito
importante
antes porque apesar da academia já ser
um pouquinho mais distante das pessoas
as organizações políticas também são
distantes das pessoas
o que a gente vê nos dois casos são
pontes que são pontes cumpridas
elas são pontes estreitas são poucas
pessoas que estão fazendo o trabalho
tanto na academia quanto na política que
está fazendo essa comunicação para fora
como a gente está fazendo aqui hoje com
pessoas estão fazendo a nos seus
esforços de comunicação ou de pesquisa
militante projeto de extensão e assim
por diante isso ainda é uma minoria e a
ponte é bastante cumprida porque a
distância é bastante grande no nosso
país em que a gente tem toda essa
questão de acesso à educação no brasil
isso é fato mas politicamente também
existem organizações políticas que
acreditam que alcançar as pessoas se
resume a discursos de cima de carros de
som ou mesmo extremamente formais com
inscrições de falar em cada plenária e
que isso seria suficiente para alcançar
as pessoas
eu diria que não eu diria que está
falhando e que é necessário a gente está
encurtando essa ponte também para que a
formação política não seja simplesmente
uma questão de quem já está em um
sindicato quem já está em um partido
político em um movimento social em algum
coletivo mas que as pessoas possam estar
prendendo de fora para elas poderem
fazer a sua formação política e quem
sabe isso leva as pessoas a se
interessarem se organizar politicamente
também e depois trazer isso de volta
porque essa ponte ela tem que ser uma
ponte de mão dupla ea outra questão é
que a própria ponte pra mim deveria
juntar à academia com militância com a
questão política porque a gente tem que
trabalhar teoria e prática no dia a dia
e aí eu penso onde é que o youtube ajuda
e atrapalha nisso youtube é um espaço
que atualmente abriga muitos vídeos
apenas a minoria desses vídeos sobre
política como a gente tem falado muito
sobre política esse ano principalmente
pela questão eleitoral
vários insultos que falam de política
ganhar um certo nível de destaque mas
nada se compara ao que a plataforma
realmente é 400 horas de vídeo são
jogadas no youtube por minuto
então desde o momento que eu comecei a
falar com vocês são milhares de horas de
vídeos novos que estão ali no youtube
nessas horas que são jogadas o tempo
inteiro se estima que um milhão de horas
de vídeos são assistidos no youtube por
dia um bilhão de horas
então é muita gente vendo muito vídeo
muito conteúdo e como é que você faz pra
você se destacar nesse espaço ainda mais
falando de política
será que seria realmente viável o que eu
diria é que a tarefa na verdade é muito
mais difícil do que parece se você pegar
mais estatísticas no youtube você vai
ver que a maior parte dos vídeos que são
muito assistido salientam na área de
música
isso ocorre porque o youtube é um espaço
em que existem profissionais e amadores
é bem importante pra gente fixar uma co
existência de conteúdo bastante
profissional ali dentro passando por
produtores passando por toda uma
estratégia ea uma coexistência de
conteúdo que é feito aleatoriamente no
celular e alguém jogou ali então ao
mesmo tempo que você procurou uma música
que você gosta no youtube e você vai ver
o clipe muito bem produzido do seu
artista favorito logo depois pode
aparecer um videozinho 60 visualizações
de um cara que gravou um cover dentro do
quarto dele com um violão e um vídeo
também escuro eo audi está ruim mas o
vídeo está lá também
então a gente vai olhar sim tem
profissionais e têm amadores ali no
youtube
mas além disso a questão é que o youtube
ainda é muito voltado para
entretenimento
apesar de a gente encontrar conteúdo
informativo educacional e política do
youtube os vídeos mais assistidos que
vão ter mais alcance sempre estarão
voltados para a questão de
entretenimento
o vídeo mais assistido no youtube é 10
pacito e o segundo vídeo brasileiro mais
assistido no youtube é uma paródia de
despacho cita então não tem muita coisa
diferente quando a gente está olhando
para os grandes grandes números dele no
youtube então será que teria espaço para
falar de política
tem espaço porque está crescendo
bastante em novos canais surgindo em
todos os campos políticos mas eu diria
que o campo político
tenso é o que mais se afastou desta
plataforma negligenciou achava que não
era importante
colocou outros nomes aquilo ali e
falaram que não se poderia falar de
política
naquela plataforma e hoje em dia todo
mundo correndo atrás do prejuízo eu
inclusive totô disposta a fazer essa
tarefa mas a gente tem encontrado alguns
problemas relacionados a isso uma em
questão recursos é muito difícil
competir no youtube com quem tem muito
mais infraestrutura que você não quer
dizer que é impossível eu comecei o meu
canal apenas com esse celular aqui que
está na minha mão e mais nada coloquei
no pezinho desses que eu comprei no
camelódromo coloquei numa cadeira e
comecei a gravar vídeo
logo depois de um tempo eu descobri que
não era suficiente porque o áudio estava
baixo e enquadramento estava estranho e
as pessoas quando está se tratando de
audiovisual elas se preocupam bastante
com forma e eu tive que buscar melhores
equipamentos e eu tive que fazer os
cursos aprender editar melhor capital
ocupando aquele espaço
mas há um abismo entre isso que eu tava
fazendo que ainda é considerado amador
com pessoas que têm bastante equipe e os
produtores estão ali
quando a gente está falando de política
isso significa também investimentos de
organizações políticas a nos seus
comunicadores que outras organizações
não estão investindo no seu próprio
campo então isso gera um dos problemas
para tentar se destacar ali
outra questão que ocorre é uma crítica
que eu faço com freqüência é que a
lógica de comunicação ali no youtube
atualmente é uma lógica muito tóxica
apesar de ser uma plataforma que permite
vídeos longos e é uma plataforma que é
muito mais voltada para o audiovisual do
que o facebook por exemplo no facebook
se você está passando o dedo na tela e
você encontra um vídeo você pensa
interessante mas não tô a fim de ver
vídeo agora e continua baixando
é uma pessoa que entra no youtube ela
entra no youtube com o objetivo de
assistir um vídeo então já tem um pouco
mais de interesse e pra você capturar a
atenção dessa pessoa
mesmo assim a lógica do entretenimento
que ainda é a maior lógico que a gente
vê ali no youtube
ela tem forçado o próprio
a ti político a ser um debate de
entretenimento então o que a gente vai
vendo que são pessoas que estão ali
simplesmente querendo absorver o
conteúdo da forma mais rápida possível
mesmo entrando em uma plataforma em que
você poderia gastar mais tempo ou
simplesmente para ver o circo pegar fogo
e colocar uma pessoa do lado da outra
refute alguém faça um debate e aí o
debate político vai ficando cada vez
mais polarizado
isso vai ter um impacto maior ainda
porque o algoritmo do youtube é um
algoritmo polarizador a pesquisadores
que trabalham com isso comunhão nas
casas e na alemanha ea gente tem visto
que a tendência se você com começa vendo
algo sobre por exemplo vou plantar uma
pequena horta caseira na minha sacada na
minha varanda
se você deixar o seu vídeo rodando pra
sempre no final você vai tá vendo algo
sobre o terrorismo
então a questão é que essa polarização
ela vai radicalizando ali no youtube
isso tem afetado a lógica de comunicação
dos próprios youtuber muitas pessoas ali
focadas em comentar em uns aos outros em
vez de estar em pauta dando os temas
políticos que julgariam mais importantes
para sua audiência o que jogariam mais
importantes nos seus objetivos
estratégicos
a questão aqui a gente acaba sendo
forçado por ser minoria a jogar junto
com um algoritmo esse algoritmo disse
que tal coisa relevante um monte de
gente para tentar ver o seu canal
crescer acaba fazendo comentários sobre
o mesmo tema vez após outra isso vai ter
um impacto sobre a questão do porquê
porque você realmente está fazendo
aquela comunicação sobre política ali é
só pra ver o seu canal crescer porque é
bom vamos ter mais visualizações daquela
forma
ou é também para a gente tá faltando
ideias novas
compartilhando idéias inspiradoras como
é o tema que hoje seria muito importante
que está fazendo essa reflexão para que
não sejamos simplesmente mas alguns
canais repetindo os mesmos conteúdos de
sempre ali naquela plataforma inclusive
de uma forma bastante tóxica e que nega
a complexidade do debate político
não se pode fazer política no youtube
falar de política no youtube
da mesma forma que se faz uma resenha do
filme
sheik por exemplo qual é mais gostoso o
chocolate ou de baunilha
mesmo se você fizer essa resenha um
monte de gente vai discordar porque esse
objetivo mas política é complexa mas
passa por questões objetivas também
apresentar dados apresentar análises
disso entra essa noção de teoria e
prática casando academia e razão da
militância isso seria bastante
importante mas as pessoas estão
impacientes se tem algum outro tubo
falando de y e você está falando de x
a pessoa não quer aprender e y e depois
disso ela quer que você já diga por que
você acha que x é melhor do que y e é
isso diminui a complexidade do que você
está tratando ele não há uma maneira de
falar da diferença entre a agroecologia
e agricultura convencional da mesma
forma que a gente compara gosto de milk
shakes em si é um dos problemas que a
gente tem
o outro problema que a gente tem pra se
destaca aline tube tem a ver com as
vozes mais marginalizados da sociedade
porque são rosas que também são
marginalizados nas redes sociais que
recebem menos destaque aqui a gente vai
falar de mulheres de pessoas negras
lgbts indígenas todas aquelas vozes que
no dia a dia não são vistas normalmente
como tendo a competência para falar
daquele tema então se você chega ali
você será julgado primariamente pelo que
você é ou a pessoa imagina que você é e
vai ser mais difícil a pessoa prestar
atenção no que você está falando algo
que eu tenho de experiência no meu dia a
dia eu também participo de podcasts e
nos podcast seu costuma ser menos
criticada do que no youtube porque as
pessoas não estão me vendo então é como
jogando minha aparência e isso entra
nessa questão do audiovisual e vai
gerando um problema de desumanização que
é freqüente
nós vamos ver isso não somente nos
xingamentos mas a gente vai ver isso
também nas críticas que muitas vezes são
destrutivas e uma lógica que prevalece é
ali que se um conteúdo não me agrada em
1% eu não vou impulsioná-los conteúdo
porém se um conteúdo e desagrado em 100%
eu vou tá falando desse conteúdo só pra
poder falar mal é uma dificuldade que a
gente encontra seria essa de recursos
iguais dessa comunicação
o que prevalece ele e uma discriminação
estrutural também e aí você poderia
falar pra mim que olha então tá um pouco
perdido você está falando de ocupar o
youtube vai falar de política mas olha
conta os desafios a gente encontra e
desses desafios eu diria que os
principais estão relacionados a esses
três aqui mas meus colegas poderiam
falar de outros também
só que como eu falei que o youtube tem
essa questão de profissionais e amadores
talvez você aqui me assistindo vai achar
que vou falar então a gente precisa
profissionalizar as pessoas até ocupando
esse espaço
mas eu quero falar o contrário do que eu
acho que o youtube precisa de mais
amadores
a gente precisa de mais pessoas ocupando
esse espaço mas só não nesse sentido
pejorativo que é dado normalmente ao que
considera a amador que é impróprio que é
inapto que não está preparado e tem o
significado que a gente encontra um
dicionário que é aquele que gosta muito
de alguma coisa que é amante que é
apreciador e que é entusiasta de algo se
você tá falando de política no youtube
na internet em geral
você precisa ser um amador porque se não
você não vai inspirar pessoas
se você tá faltando política que seja
voltada para a transformação social que
seja voltada para mais ação política que
o que você tentando fazer ali é não ser
simplesmente um influenciador mais um
multiplicador que as outras pessoas
também estejam agindo
você precisa ser um amador e você
precisa diminuir a distância entre as
pessoas
e aí o que eu acho muito interessante é
que é difícil fazer isso quando você
está sendo desorganizado constantemente
principalmente quando você está falando
de política ea expectativa das pessoas
falar de política encontrar alguém que
tem aparência e avós e os títulos que
ela espera de alguém que fala de
política de forma séria
em um comentário que eu recebi uma vez
mais para o começo do canal em que o
cara me falava que olha concordo
práticamente com tudo o que você falou
aqui mas eu acho muito difícil de levar
a sério o que você faz muitas caras e
bocas ea expectativa dessa pessoa eu não
quis jogar ela no momento mas eu sabia
qualquer expectativa dela quando se fala
de política por aí você espera alguém
uma forma extremamente formal ou
ostentando os seus títulos
há ali pra cá que não tem nada errado
com os títulos mais sendo validados por
espaços formais tanto na na academia
quanto a gente vai encontrar na
militância no jornalismo e assim por
diante e aí parece que não seria viável
uma pessoa está falando de política no
youtube
existem umas coisas coloridas atrás
delas é uma mulher que gosta de
maquiagem e olha achei no começo que
seria problemático mas refletindo sobre
a questão de senador
eu pensei que olha o que eu posso fazer
agora é mostrar justamente isso que eu
estou no youtube ocupando esse espaço
junto com essa comunidade de outros de
tubos falando de política que pauta
transformação social porque a gente ama
a causa
a gente é uma causa ea gente trabalha
muito duro por isso inclusive é trabalho
esse reconhecimento de que você está
fazendo ali não é um hobby mas tem
investimento de tempo e gera valor e
muita gente está tentando sobreviver
dessa forma e aí eu passei a amar um
pouquinho mais as minhas caras e bocas
porque eu faço muitas mesmo toda vez que
eu estou editando um vídeo no youtube eu
fico até chocada quando eu consigo tenho
esse monte de expressão estranha quando
falo de coisas às vezes muito simples
mas não é tão complicado assim tá
mostrando as suas caras e bocas na
verdade eu acho que é isso que a gente
precisa hoje para fazer uma comunicação
mais humanizada
a gente precisa se organizar e fazer um
pouquinho de graça com a gente de vez em
quando mostrar que nós somos pessoas
normais do dia a dia e que você que é
normal do dia a dia também faz política
junto com a gente e que está lhe
faltando alguma coisa no youtube algumas
mais visualizações não faz de ninguém em
especial mas faz aquela pessoa bastante
responsável e se ela é responsável por
tentar mudar as coisas
ela tem com o como uma perspectiva sim
mostrar suas caras e bocas e multiplicar
isso para que a gente veja mais caras e
bocas de outras pessoas ali a gente
precisa de mais humanização pra que a
gente entenda que o outro que está lhe
faltando uma política que é diferente da
sua ele é uma pessoa que ele tem
objetivos
ele é uma pessoa que não está ali por
acaso então é importante a gente
trabalhar com isso
e principalmente mostrar essa questão do
mais amor à causa porque quando a gente
está falando de política no genérico
talvez não seja necessário demonstrar
isso mas pra gente fazer transformação
social
a gente precisa ter capacidade de
inspirar as pessoas ea gente precisa ter
capacidade está mobilizando pessoas
também tenham mais amor à causa que vai
fazer com que os nossos vídeos que eles
não sejam somente mais alguns vídeos
nessas 400 horas por minuto
ali no youtube por dentro de si um
bilhão de horas que são assistidas por
dia mas que elas sigam realmente a idéia
do tasy 11 e que na verdade não é o meu
canal que está falando mas da tese 11
que me inspirou que mostra pra mim que é
muito necessário hoje em dia a gente a
faltar todo o debate que a gente faz no
dia a dia entre a gente está
transformando o mundo ea gente saber que
os nossos vídeos eles podem ser vídeos
que não geram somente debates mas que
estejam investigando as pessoas a agir
também que estraga uma forma de
multiplicação
[Aplausos]